Buenas noches Santiago no sé si escuchas
detrás de mí el concierto y la
celebración que está viendo y que la
lluvia no ha impedido que cientos de
mujeres vuelvan a salir a la calle aquí
frente a la corte constitucional de
Colombia para celebrar como decías el
año de la despenalización del aborto
hasta la semana 24 de gestación
recordemos que desde 2006 ya emperaba un
sistema de tres causales que impera
ahora a partir de estas 24 semanas sin
embargo como dice sigue habiendo
barreras que afectan Pues precisamente a
las mujeres más vulnerables para hablar
de esto tenemos con nosotros a Juliana
Martínez que ella es miembro del
movimiento causa justa esta agrupación
de más de 200 organizaciones que hizo
este litigio para la corte para
despenalizar el aborto Juliana Cuáles
son estas barreras que todavía persisten
y qué balance hacen de ese año el
balance que hace causa justa Este primer
año incluye por supuesto la celebración
de esta gran herramienta que permite que
las mujeres puedan abortar por su propia
decisión pero también hace un balance
sobre los retos que siguen en la
despenalización social no nos
conformamos con el cambio legal queremos
que el cambio suceda en todos los
ámbitos donde las mujeres puedan
necesitar un aborto y que también sea
una conversación que se dé cada vez de
manera más tranquila sin La amenaza de
la pena y sin ningún tipo de culpas
precisamente este estas amplitudes de la
semana 24 y causó mucha polémica en el
país sin embargo en este los datos de
este último año dicen que solo el 12%
menos del 12% de las mujeres acceden a
un aborto a partir de la semana 24 de
gestación y son precisamente las mujeres
más vulnerables de los territorios más
apartados las que necesitan este plazo
Colombia se convierte así como decimos
en uno de los países con una regulación
más amplia en materia de derechos para
las mujeres